[Music]
maurice what a pleasure chess in the
parks chess in the parks this is where i
grew up playing chess like for me this
is this is home playing in new york city
playing in brooklyn prospect park
uh even into manhattan washington square
park it was always a lot of fun oh for
me it's always been like that i've had
the pleasure of playing around the world
in different parks and you get to meet
this real hustlers you can see their
tactics their tricks it's been amazing
and
i think new york has the trickiest ones
man those guys in in new york city they
have mastered the art of the hustle
first of all there's always got to be
trash talking like there's no chess
without trash talking we play in the the
club we do commentary in the club and
everybody's quiet and all no
you better take your feelings and park
them somewhere because guys are going to
talk about your mama about your sister
about your best friends and about your
chess moves and you have to be on top of
stuff
i've seen players they're beat up titled
players that come in their confidence
trotting like they know what's going on
they say
park players amateurs i can beat them up
i've seen them you know go home being
just on the receiving end of some nasty
tricks well the legends of the park you
got guys like
vinnie livermore
ralph mouth
lightning sam all these guys they knew
how to get inside your head the point is
you think you're playing chess but
you're listening to them at the same
time and you know just the right thing
to say to throw you off and there's an
art to that there's an art to
distraction
that's what it's all about when you're
playing and then you have like the nasty
tricks sometimes in the old school
jurgers you know the analog clocks
somehow your side would move a little
faster like wait a minute how come my
time is down already or you got the
hustle where when it got down to the
blitz how suddenly all the moves they
made were close to the clock every move
every move was on the side of the clock
so that your flag would fall before
theirs did it was always some kind of
trickery to get your money out of your
pocket money out of your pocket but i
think you've gone around new york how
did it feel the experience of playing
against them man i was playing in the
park and i get my butt kicked getting my
money taking my lunch money taken by
these guys it was just the way you
learned it was just part of being a
chess player in the parks not only also
with the trash talking scene you know
you had a bunch of guys just hanging out
sometimes ladies you'd have music
playing you'd be saying sirens police
cars were going by i'm talking about
this was the hood fulton park as well
and we would just that would be normal
for us so to me that kind of cutthroat
atmosphere
where it was all about winning and you
might get your money taken really
prepared me for what would come when i
was in clubs and you know nobody be
quiet
everything was just high-end yeah for me
it was the same way i grew up a blitz
player i went to in costa rica and i
just played gangsters you know they
would like hustle for absolutely no
money but that was all they had
and i had to learn how to be tricky i
was actually had to slow myself down
when i became a norm hunter because i
was just playing too quickly and too
tricky uh but it's always been part of
my culture as well and i love going
around the world to different parks and
just seeing people play luxembourg park
absolutely paris absolutely gorgeous
around moscow you can see people playing
all over i had a great time in havana
and i was just going around the park and
i saw i wasn't even planning on going to
play chess and i was just seeing some
people you know
playing for fun i checked it out
man they were good
man they were solid chess players you
can see the attacks you can see the
tricks they were playing some theory i
was like
not easy anymore park chess can't be
underestimated you know it's funny when
i was playing i remember what the the
park players they used to try to play in
tournaments right but even playing in
tournaments they tried to hustle it
right they keep their ratings down they
wouldn't they you know under section
maybe they might you might one or two
sandbaggers might show up all right show
that they could blend in under 2 000
sections under 1800
000 and try to win money these guys were
2200 strength in blitz but you know it
was funny because they wouldn't be able
to sit still for hours on end they'd be
like yo make a move man because they're
used to going like this so they'd be
sitting there and they'd come out they
would rarely win big money at those
tournaments it was a difference between
park chess and serious over the board
tournaments yeah and they and they would
tell me to try to keep mine raiding down
i was like come on i'm trying to get my
grand master i'm not going to keep my
rating low but it was always about the
hustle and that would keep them back
they would keep them back but man
they're tricky sometimes you see them
play against strong players
i would say even up to feed a master
international master level and you'd see
man the 1600 um you know that's not
right so that is absolutely not right
how do they know so many tricks and
sometimes the positional understanding
it's not there it's that flick of the
wrist i'm gonna trip you i'm gonna trick
you and
very dangerous people auto tactics
matter of fact there's a video of me
playing a hustler in washington square
park and he tried to take well i won't
spoil it for people who would watch it
just to say he did a move i'd never seen
tried
ever like ever in the history of my
playing chess it is after years and
years i mean decades of playing and i
played this game i saw i was like
this guy actually pulled this hustle
trying to cheat in the middle of a game
and i respected him for it i was like
that was funny like you actually
practiced that and try to pull it off he
could have done it a lot better i still
would have seen it but it was a great
great move
i i think it's just a resourcefulness
when it comes down to it the practice of
being resourceful at so many different
things in chess and i love the
creativity they bring to it it's the
clock it's the tactic it's the it's the
doom i'm not really sure where the
pieces i love that one it could be on
two four squares at once place no my
bishop just changed color what are you
talking about in the middle you're like
wait how did that bishop i thought it
was a white square bishop now it's a
dark square bishop stuff like that is
just priceless and you gotta lend for
defend for yourself nobody's gonna be
like yeah of course that bishop no you
gotta fight for your rights in those
games there's no arbiter to call over
hey chris bird can i have some
adjournment no
i don't know
you're in the middle of the war and it's
fun like i said the trash talking
uh the the music
the joy of the game the fun of it and
the cutthroat aspect you'll see people
standing around a chess board in a park
and watching
like they're watching magnus cross and
play hikaru nakamura because people are
showing off it's the when hikaru and
magnus and all these guys they play a
brilliant move you know they played and
they they might adjust their piece a
little bit more than another you're on a
party like boom baby i'm here to play
chess come watch i'm playing this
brilliancy it's just a different
atmosphere and the language uh will get
a little um
you know let's just say we can't talk
talk about that when we're at the st
louis chess club yeah but
the flamboyance and the language guys
would be quoting shakespeare
people like who's this guy and they're
mixing in street with
old school classical
everything it says i think i think it
would make a great show
if it was all about purchase it would i
think i made great tv maurice i'm
getting fired up let's let's play some
chances let's do it
this is i feel like i'm back back and
you can't even make moves man come on
you're trying to cheat me i'm nervous
nervous just making me nervous play
chess look at this guy you name it pack
it give me a break this is a boring this
is how you play chess
my sister plays better than this you
don't even know how to play chess do you
want to pass from the fourth record
out of here that lady ain't got no no
come on give me a break forward oh this
guy do you know how to pass the fourth
rank